this morning we are beginning with two
of our featured speakers and for many of
you you're familiar with the first
because you've also taken some courses
with him either here at Teachers College
or at the Columbia School of Public
Health and I'm specifically speaking
about dr. Robert E fully love and so as
you may know he's associate dean for
community in minority affairs professor
of clinical associate medical sciences
at the Melbourne School of Public Health
co-director of the Canadian research
group at the new york state psychiatric
institute co-director of a new program
urbanism and the built environment with
his wife dr. mini fully love and the
Department of sochi medical sciences and
his wife is a psychiatrist I'm sure let
it be cleaned up and it's a little
discussion about psychologists can be
culturally appropriate so without
further ado and of course what we're
going to do for the second part we're
going to go directly I mom obviously
there that ok so Tiger we're talking
about 42 minutes for dr. Robert E fully
love let's give it up from what we love
and there's another thing about dr. full
of the nascent especially wonderful
historically he has been on more
dissertation committee than anyone else
at Teachers College clem university as
an adjunct okay so we believe want to
give it up morning everyone glad you
could make it out on such an ugly
morning ah I was actually originally
going to do PowerPoint and then as soon
as I got here it dogma made that I know
so many of you that it would probably be
really something of a shock to the
system if I were actually to a lot of
people naughty so you know what I'm
right if i were to sort of try to do the
division between what you see on the
screen and what you're hearing me trying
to say especially since this is what I
would describe as a kind of an intimate
gathering and what I'm really most
interested in doing is reflecting on
something that really haunted me last
night when I recognize that number one
this is the absolute end of Black
History Month 2008 the number two as a
result of speaking at so many black
history month events I have started to
really think about what it means to be
someone who was born in the 1940s and
who just celebrated 64 years of life and
is trying to use the experience of
having been in this country for more
than 60 years to deal with and
understand and put in perspective the
issue of health disparities which at
least in my family has gone through many
many iterations many of you know that
I'm the grandson of a physician dr.
Robert full of love seniors started
practicing medicine in 1896 in the state
of Mississippi and was one of the first
African American physicians son of a
slave to be in that position in a in a
city that almost never no one has ever
heard of Yazoo City my dad dr. Robert
full of junior started practicing
medicine in 1934 and for 52 years before
his death he was someone who was
familiar with practicing medicine in the
south having been board certified as a
physician while he was in private
practice in New Orleans and having done
a great deal in the north as a physician
living in working in Newark New Jersey
treating sexually transmitted diseases
as a urologist an irony by the way that
was lost on him the notion that his last
name was full of love and that gonorrhea
basically was paying the bills and
putting his sons in prep school in
college I'm married to Mindy Thompson
full of this professor Wallace indicated
who is this a kind
interest who celebrates 30 years of
practicing medicine having graduated
from Columbia pns in 1978 and I'm
someone who has had like three very
distinct identities in the course of
what I like to consider now is a long
life I talked about black history month
because part of what people these days
are most interested in hear me talk
about is not what I do professionally
what they're really interested in is
what it was like for me between 1963 in
1968 when I was very active in the civil
rights movement when I was a field
secretary for the Student Nonviolent
Coordinating Committee snick when I had
as was the case with almost anybody who
worked in the state of Mississippi are
in the state of Alabama in the civil
rights movement frequent contact with
dr. King and as a result of that find
myself often and talking to audiences
during Black History Month about the
degree to which people absolutely
forgotten what those errors were like
when you talk to kids in high school
Black History Month consists of a day on
the civil rights movement where you
learn that there were two people who
were involved Rosa Parks and dr. King
and then that was it you go from the
Montgomery boycott the Birmingham
demonstrations to modern times so the
notion that there was so much stuff in
between that is lost then there's this
identity I have as somebody who's been
working in public health or last 20
years someone who has looked at the
evolution of the discourse on health
disparities and who finds that the
attempt to sort of reconcile all of this
what it's been like to live in a family
of physicians that traces its roots back
to the 19th century to have been
involved in one of the most important
IRA's of the 20th century and then to be
working in an area that continually
tries to understand how you bring the
historical momentum that was created
into the creative than the civil rights
movement into the 20th century to talk
about health disparities what what's the
way of reconciling all of it and that is
really basically what I've decided it
would be most important
focus on in a conversation I would love
to have with you today about health
disparities and what we do about it now
I mentioned that also because in the
many years I've been engaged in doing
public health research and public health
quality excuse me public health policy
word I've had occasion to serve on a lot
of policymaking bodies if you read the
bio that is given in the program you see
that I've spent a lot of time with the
institute of medicine and the National
Academy of Sciences both is a member of
one of their boards as well as as a
member of five different IOM committees
I've also been a reviewer for I or when
reports so I understand something about
what happens when the United States
government often in the person of the
Congress of the United States asks the
medical and public health community to
weigh in on issues that ultimately will
have budgetary impact legislative impact
and practice impact when they think
about the relationship between our laws
or regulations in the way in which we
practice medicine and do the work of
Public Health so I've been thinking
about that a lot I've also been very
clear that over the course of the last
couple of years somebody who does a
great deal of work with HIV that we are
in the midst of a quite difficult point
in our understanding of HIV and what
we're supposed to do about it those of
us who started back in the 1980s this is
my 23rd year of being engaged in AIDS
research those of us who started back in
that era remember when the fight against
HIV was the fight to prevent it it was a
uniformly fatal disease so the only real
public health response we had was to
come up with programs that would prevent
people from getting infected and it is
there that I think we started what I
would consider to be the most important
aspects of the discourse about health
disparities from a policy standpoint
I've always worried
that beginning with HIV and ending more
or less with some of the things that
professor Wallace was just talking about
namely what do we do about folk who are
dealing with problems related to
substance abuse I've worried that the
discourse on health disparities appears
to Center our actions our activities our
research and our policy formation on
individuals if you say that the problems
with morbidity and mortality in the
United States are basically the problems
of people of color then you make them
the unit of analysis you may then the
unit of activity and make them the unit
of concern that's another way of saying
that in order to fix health disparities
we have to fix the people who suffer
most from its consequences which is an
interesting approach but it overlooks
the degree to which many of the health
conditions that we worry most of our
most about are not necessarily under the
control of the individual nor are they
likely to cede to the kinds of
interventions where we try to get people
to act better it's not always clear that
people live in a world where the choices
that are available to them allow them to
act in their best interest again
harkening back to the link between drug
abuse and HIV many of us who work in
this field have taught it to people who
know full well the consequences of using
needles that have not been cleaned or
engaging in unprotected sex but we've
also heard folks describe the demons
that drive them to believe that the only
way they're going to get through the day
is to take another hit and we've talked
to people who have engaged in
unprotected sex because they were hungry
or because they needed shelter or
because they needed protection and
aligning yourself with somebody who was
bigger and stronger and having sex with
hims one of the ways in which you got
through the night in this instance one
of the most fundamental assumptions that
those of us as healthcare providers hold
on to that people should do anything in
their power to assure that they remain
in good health and that
long their lives as long as possible we
quickly begin to see that that
assumption is not necessarily true for
all the folk with homework if you've got
other priorities where what happens 15
years from now is an abstraction if
you've got other priorities we're
getting through the night becomes the
number one concern the number one
priority that you're living with then a
lot of the things that we do in the way
of prevention they try to convince
people it's in your best interest to
behave differently simply aren't going
to work what we really would want to do
would be to alter the nature of the
environment that limits the choices that
people have so drastically so that by
changing that environment we broaden
their choices and give them an
opportunity to do the kinds of things
and decide the kinds of things that will
prolong their lives and protect those
whom they love so what does that mean
for those of us who are engaged right
now in a conversation about eliminating
disparities in health where where are we
supposed to be dead if the unit of
analysis is not changing individual
behavior and I'm not saying that there
aren't a lot of things that we need to
do to make people more responsible for
the health I'm just saying that if our
major focus is going to be on coming up
with the most effective strategies
possible where would we look and what
would we do I have a couple of bucks on
that but I hope that you chair with me
in this one is that for the most part
when you do work in communities one of
the first things that you discover and
I'm talking specifically about the
communities that have inordinately high
rates of morbidity and mortality from a
Brian for a wide variety of sources what
are the first things that you see is
that while everybody is concerned about
their health it's not necessarily their
first priority meaning it's not
necessarily the thing that they drop it
everything right now that they're doing
to work on with you to make better they
want to be healthy they're concerned
about access to health care but if you
said okay I need you to come to this
meeting or I need you to take part in
this program or I need you to show up at
this conference they've got other things
to do so what happens when you say well
what are the things that you really most
interested in what are the things that
you're willing to fight for what are the
things that you're willing to organize
around so that we change the conditions
that contribute so enormously to the
port health of the community let me just
be clear that this is a question that
you're much more likely to hear from a
community organizer then you want from
somebody who does health policy research
you recall that I said that there was a
time in my life when I was heavily
engaged in civil rights movement what I
did in the two and a half years that are
worked in Mississippi that it worked as
a community organizer the age of 20 that
was probably to this day one of the most
successful periods in my life because I
really saw a direct relationship between
what I did and the impact it had on the
communities in which I was working and I
think I've never forgotten never stepped
very far away from the lessons that I
think you learn when you're actually in
a community and you're trying to get
people to join with you in creating what
sociologists now described as collective
efficacy that is to say the capacity of
a group to join together to make
decisions about what they're going to do
and how they're going to do it and then
app on those decisions in a way that
brings about a mutually desired set of
results so what do you learn from the
handbook that community organizers use
in doing their work well the first and
most important thing is there are often
two different agendas and play there's
their agenda and then there's your
agenda unfortunately those of us who do
health education and those of us who do
Public Health often come in with our own
agenda which is largely informed by
surveillance statistics so we walk into
a community and say you know y'all got a
real problem with syphilis oh man it's
bad it's costing y'all money or I'm
really concerned about your high rates
of teenage pregnancy you know how many
young women in this town have babies
before they're 16 or we walk in worried
about the degree to which folks are
diabetic y'all fat y'all got problems
with the junction blood sugar and every
time I walk into one of the local
restaurants what do I see I see foods
that are ultimately killing you got to
stop that is there any wonder that when
we start to have conversations that
begin with here's what's wrong with you
people immediately turn off not only do
they turn off because there's a sense in
which we're beginning with a deficit
model of dealing with health disparities
that is to say we're telling them what's
wrong with them there's also a problem
because more than anything else that's
not what they really care about and it's
not just that it's not what they really
care about of course they're concerned
but we failed to do the one thing that
in many of our communities is the most
important and forgive me the most polite
we thought we forgotten to ask them well
what do you want to do I mean it's a
small point but to the degree that we
walk them with degrees with articles
with grants meaning with money we think
that well after all my education my
publications by wealth of knowledge and
my cash really give me a certain right
to call the shots now I'm not hating
I've done this before I'm not saying
that I'm free of this not at all but
after 23 years of doing this I have
observed that that isn't necessarily the
kind of approach that really works
rhetorical question but how many of you
have been involved in a health
intervention where the first thing you
wanted to do was
hold a town meeting where you would talk
about the issues you've lined up all
kinds of speakers you've advertised in
the newspapers maybe the local community
newspapers you've had public service
announcements on TV and on radio you've
asked ministers or clergy in the
community to announce your meeting from
the pulpit you showed up a lot of you
know where I'm going with this you've
showed up at the door and there were six
people there for whom were speakers and
the other two are married to the
speakers what's wrong with this picture
we did everything we could to pass the
word and we tried as much as possible to
convince people that this was really
serious that what we're about is having
a conversation that has life or death
consequences and because they have life
or death consequences we're so astounded
that we throw a party and nobody comes
well I want to suggest again that the
community organizers handbook says well
you came in basically following a
textbook example of how you're supposed
to do this but I'm actually necessarily
asking people so Oh what kind of thing
would get you out on a saturday morning
or a friday night or a weekday night to
talk to your neighbors about what's
going on it's a small point but we are
so driven by the kinds of language we
use in our grants to get the funding to
do this that we often overlook some of
the basic principles having to do with
how human beings decide that they're
going to group together work together
and ultimately produce things that are
beneficial for all involved I'm trying
to suggest that maybe the first way to
begin to deal with the issue of health
disparities is not to talk about health
it all that we talked about the things
that people care about what happens if
you ask people so what are the things
that you care about I actually think
that I could pull all of you in this
right now and you and I would come up
with probably the same set of answers
which is spooky is that because we
already know the answers but we don't
act on it we know that people really are
concerned about employment and job
opportunities hello we're working in
communities where unemployment often
exceeds 50 percent we're working in
communities where adults that we are
concerned about have never had a
legitimate job in their lives so that
they're concerned about employment is
kind of a no-brainer the second thing
that they're probably going to tell you
that they're really worried about is
housing especially if you're working
here in New York the average New Yorker
is now paying more than thirty percent
of his income just to keep a roof over
his or her head there are plenty of
communities where that figure exceeds 50
percent and let me say that this
includes folk with degrees from Columbia
University our young came from someplace
else to be in New York City you love the
glamour and the attraction of New York
are yourselves hypnotized by this notion
and by the way I live in Jersey so it's
easy for me to say this i hypnotized by
the notion of Jordan you're in Mecca
you're in the land of magic what if you
see thought I really feel about Don
jalandhar you're hearing it in the city
that's the most important in the world
the only place i know that's like this
is bias which is why I broke into French
because I hear the same thing from from
those folks as well and she will
probably fall sleep issues I mean
subject imelda quarter power so the
whole notion that people are here and
doing that and somehow separate what
they consider to be their own madness
from those of folks that they're working
with is an important thing for us to
keep in mind i'm coming back to the
notion that affordable housing is i
would have to say counts is one of the
primary issues not just facing poor
communities but every single person in
the united states except those who are
so obscenely rich that excitement worth
talking about them the whole question of
affordable housing is something that has
been disappearing slowly but surely over
the course of
the last 50 years and we haven't really
paid attention to it enough in the
discourse on health disparities and
that's largely because we take it for
granted we take it for granted that if
you're not doing work with the homeless
the housing is just part of the backdrop
but there's reason why I think we have
to think about housing as one of those
issues that people really care about
I'll come back to that in a second the
third thing that I think is very much
involved in the work that I'm doing now
and this does affect poor communities of
color disproportionately is the issue of
mass incarceration I don't know of any
family mine included that doesn't have
somewhere in its immediate extended
circle somebody who's doing time in the
joint somebody who is in in prison on
parole under the supervision of the
court or living in the shadow of having
done something stupid and having done
jail time in order to pay for it I'm
suggesting that that changes so much of
the outlook of young men in the
community in particular that to not
recognize how much people are concerned
with the disappearance of our young men
off the street that to not recognize how
much that's sort of in the back of
everyone's mind is to overlook an
opportunity to get communities talking
to each other about what they're going
to do with problems that they're all
feeling in common why is important for
us to think about these kinds of issues
why isn't it important for us to begin a
conversation with other kinds of issues
then those that were funded to talk
about and those that were funded to work
on because I don't see any other way to
rally community support behind what it
is we do here's what happens when you
have the other conversation part of what
makes anyone who's working in a
community effective is the degree to
which they trust what you do there's a
kind of an unexamined assumption in
public health that what makes us
effective is the amount of money that we
have so a lot of us get brands that
involve are demonstrating our capacity
to work with community-based
organizations and other community
institutions like churches we send in
grants with memorandum of agreement
memorandum of agreement for those of you
speak Latin forgive me and we
demonstrate that each person is going to
get a slice of whatever pie we're giving
and as a result of that we can count on
them for their support okay well this is
true but there's something sort of
artificial about it because what's
driving the conversation isn't a concern
for the problem that we're being funded
to take care of what's driving the
conversation is simple economic need in
communities that have no resources the
golden rule applies right you remember
the Golden Rule he who has the gold
cause the rules well that's how we're
operating so why are we surprised when
other people who aren't getting a slice
of the pie don't see the problems that
are so pressing for us with the same
point of you with the same concern of
the same passion now I'm suggesting that
it is for that reason that we have to
sort of reconfigure our notions about
what it means to work in the community
by thinking about issues of trust what
builds relationships that allow people
to go the extra mile to work on problems
that we all see confine the community
well number one is the it's the notion
that you're not there because you have
money you're there because you're
someone who can be trusted and what does
you trust me in an arm field that I'm
not going to conduct a study collect a
bunch of data and then disappear once
the grant is over then I'm not going to
write an article that describes all the
evils that exist in the community and as
a result of having this article
published and widely cited stigmatize
the folk who participated in the study
that I'm not going to promise both that
as a result of doing this kind of
research things are going to get better
because of what I'm going to learn when
after 50 years of public health research
that's basically not been the case show
me a community where some piece of
research has dramatically improved the
quality lives of the people life of the
of the folks that we work with there are
examples there are examples don't let me
for one minute suggest that we aren't
effective and what we do but I'm saying
that the number of times that has not
happened far outweighs the number of
times that it has and as a consequence
why should we be surprised at Folkestone
always trust this so how do you build
trust 11 you come in and you spend
enough time in a community so that
people actually get to know you now what
does that mean that they actually get to
know you it doesn't mean that they
should see you all the time at meetings
but they see you in other kinds of
settings where you're doing something
for them for which are not asking
payment and for which you're not
demanding there'd be some kind of quid
pro quo some kind of return that if
somebody says I need you to have I need
to have you come speak to my young
people does you do that even though it
may not be something that's funded by
the grand that the whole notion about
building trust is people will work with
folks that they know but after 50 years
of working with folks that they don't
know who ripped them off it becomes that
much harder for us to convince the
people that we want to work with that we
somehow are different well known the way
you demonstrate that you're different is
by doing things differently don't come
in with the same script doing the same
things expecting different results the
community organizers handbook always
says people have to see it they have to
see you in the small places that to see
in the large places and you have to know
that they can count on you the only way
we're going to really begin this
dialogue I'm suggesting is by making
sure that people know us for other
things than the activities for which
we're funded second point that any it's
really associated with that is the whole
notion that people also need to know
that there is in fact something in it
for them and I'm not talking here about
money I'm talking
about the degree to which we talk about
ways in which we are able to demonstrate
to people that small actions can produce
large results one of the most effective
helm community organizing strategies I
ever saw had to do with college kids
from a community that can't name because
I think this is actually a publication
that's under pressed who worked with
high school kids to help them get into
college turns out that in the local high
schools the kind of career counseling
and college counseling that many of us
in this room benefited from simply does
not exist the young public health
students were involved in this project
came from all over the country had gone
to all kinds of different colleges were
willing to write letters on behalf of
students introducing young people in
this group that they were working with
to the schools that they were interested
in attending organized college visit
some of which were paid for by the
college and Erin get an enormous amount
of goodwill simply because a lot of the
kids who went on these trips left the
community and traveled to another state
for the first time in their lives seem
like such a small thing it wasn't paid
for by the grand but the amount of
goodwill that it earned had a lot to do
with at the point they wanted to do the
health fair having large numbers of
people show up here's a final point that
I think we all have to confront and this
goes back to an issue I wanted to talk
about earlier than I raised earlier a
very sage public health scientist whose
work I trust and admire greatly Michael
Marmot has often pointed out that our
very American approach I think is the
word to use towards problems is to fail
to understand how much all of us are in
this together he used to say that if you
really looked at health you see the
it exists on a continuum and in a
complex interactive society like ours
where we're just one system we fail to
understand the degree to which what
happens to people at the bottom at some
levels affects people at the top he said
one of the most foolish strategies that
one could implement would be one in
which we focus all of our resources on
folks at the bottom and fail to
understand the degree to which were all
sort of in this together that our
problems are all interconnected housing
is I think the best example of this the
subprime crisis first hit poor
communities of color hardest because
those are the folk who are in
communities where almost everybody had a
very low credit rating but everybody
wanted to participate in the American
dream of owning a house so they got
loans for houses that they couldn't
possibly afford and it got sort of
suckered into something that made a lot
of other people money and created a
situation that for many and relatively
poor working-class communities has now
reached crisis proportions but the thing
about Marvin's point are we clear that
now that crisis has now become worldwide
it doesn't just affect our communities
it affects everybody it affects credit
markets it affects more than just
housing the the confidence that people
have in the stock market going up to and
including hedge funds has been severely
shaded so we're really looking at a
worldwide meltdown that first made its
appearance with us but now affects
everybody sort of proof of the degree to
which we're all in this together we are
all part of a larger system that is very
tightly interconnected and not
necessarily amenable to the kinds of
interventions that only work with a part
of the problem and not with all the
problem and here's where I think this
stuff gets really critical all of us are
in a situation where we expect I'm
talking particularly to folk who do
public health that the financing for the
work we do will come from
public sector what does it feel like if
you're in ohio or in any other state in
the Rust Belt where the large rate of
default on housing loans is so bad the
rates of foreclosures are so high that
governments no longer had the tax income
necessary to pay for the services that
are necessary how many cities are at the
point of bankruptcy and as a result
really basically are unable to pay the
high price for the public health
interventions that we know are necessary
i started this talk by saying that
probably the biggest weakness we all
share is our dependence on soft money if
there's no cash out there to do more
work that work doesn't get done does it
nobody doesn't stuff for free here's a
here's a point that I often like to make
in a black history talk in which I
described the civil rights movement the
civil rights movement was not funded by
federal grants small print but it's
rather important the revolution will not
be funded it's a small what a lot of us
are doing right now is trying to perfect
our ability to get an edge in the
competition for an ever-dwindling pot of
money right what's really trading the
lifeblood of this country is this war
three trillion dollars and dead the
dollar is sinking faster than the
Titanic our money is not buying what it
used to which means that health care
costs are going to continue to rise
we're printing money in order to do that
taxpayer thing but that's all we're
doing we're printing money the actual
value of that money hasn't changed any
and with those of you who drove here and
had to fill up
your tank before you got here you're
probably going to be doing what the
Snickers for lunch as opposed to going
to one of the restaurants down there
what is happening to the entire country
if we are thinking of the creation of a
health disparities agenda that will be
funded with state municipal or federal
funds we have to face the fact that we
are in for a long dark night where that
funding is not going to be available
some of us will get it but the problem
with some of us getting it is really
literally all the others who don't what
happens to the problems that we
described in our grants and contracts
what happens to the issues that we're
asking our colleagues to address they're
not going to go away just because we
don't get the money and here's what I've
seen in HIV as it has felt the pinch of
a switch from prevention to medical care
that people leave and they go do other
things I can't tell you how many of my
colleagues who used to do i'm talking
about black male professors in
institutions that do all kinds of health
research i'm talking the ones who used
to be involved in hiv/aids we're now
doing diabetes obesity and
cardiovascular disease because that's
where the cash is i'm not i'm not hating
on him they're very clear about that
there's being televised I'm not hating
I'm just pointing out that you know you
got a choice you can do God's work those
are things that kill our folk in greater
numbers than HIV but to the degree that
we're all basically being buffeted by
market forces that we continue to have
these conversations as if the money will
always be there as if the resources will
always be present and what we need to do
is refine our research agendas so that
we come up with better ways of
developing interventions that are
make a difference is basically to
indulge in a fantasy and ain't gonna
happen that way a lot of us are going to
have to go to ground we're going to have
to go to the communities we're going to
have to be there and the work that we're
going to do is not necessarily going to
be funded but I guarantee it's going to
be God's work our communities have
gotten disorganized what's changed
between the civil rights movement and
now fundamentally one thing we no longer
see ourselves as members of a community
who are working together as a collective
they don't get me wrong I'm not talking
about those as being the good old days
they were not there's nothing good about
they're just different and the way they
were different is I could count on my
neighbor to show up at church with me to
talk about something that was affecting
both of us right now I go into a lot of
communities and what I see is people who
want to get out who do not see
themselves they're all making common
cause with their neighbors who see that
in the competition for dwindling
resources their neighbors aren't so much
their colleagues their competitors and
may I say that this also goes through
those true for all the organizations
that are working in this area of health
disparities we're not collaborators
we're competitors that in that kind of
world the classic divide-and-conquer
strategy has worked as long as we
continue the obsessive chase after the
ever-dwindling grant dollar the problem
with health disparities will remain with
us and if anything it will get worse the
modest proposal which I admit is
somewhat revolutionary is that some of
us are going to have to have a day job
where we pay the bills and a night job
in what you do the work that brought us
together at this conference in the first
place it isn't going to be funded but
history proves that when people are
determined when they have the will and
when they have the capacity to be
trusted the people will follow the only
way we're going to get rid of health
disparities is to have communities
decide that this is their fight we're
not there yet but lord willing and with
your help someday we will
ok we have freedom instructor questions
yes any questions for dr. Floyd but what
I'd like to ask first of all I want to
thank you for that wonderful talk and
what you miss yesterday was that we've
got a conference call for a 21st century
global civil rights movement for help
and we actually had people put out that
call three times I am calling for and so
your talk was perfect insofar as you've
given us a lot of practical advice about
how we begin to make that movement
happen so um since we have a minute and
30 seconds would you just like to make a
very pointed comet to for example
graduate students who are being trained
to do their dissertations to do research
freudenberg suggested and is actually
developed an advocacy course but is
there something specific that you just
might underline there's one more time
that the people of this room who are
graduate students and professionals
might do to really make such a movement
I mean you answered it but if you just
underline it what would I what I doing
what would I say um I think there are
large numbers of folk who in addition to
what they do is students and as junior
faculty there's a lot of what they do
involves things like mentoring that is
to say they do a lot of volunteer
activity ah that is not paid for it's
really out of a variety of things
sometimes they're simply giving back I
think people see that as what they do
for themselves and everything else is
what they do to pay the bills I would
like to see that script lift ever so
slightly I'm not saying that you should
give up all you have
and go to serve the poor that makes no
sense but I am suggesting that anybody
who's in this institution is already a
workaholic you already are accustomed to
working 80 90 hour weeks Oh the issue is
if you're going to continue to work at
that pace can we work in a way in which
we do what we have to do to keep the job
but are more efficient in our use with
the other time that we make available to
work with the people that we love and
that we know aren't touched by the
things that were paid to do how do you
do that many of you are members of faith
communities they continue to be as they
wear in the civil rights movement the
absolute bedrock of what we do to
organize our communities because in many
places there are the only institutions
that are left standing that what brings
people to church on Sunday morning is
often the same kind of spirit that I try
to suggest as present when community to
organize and want to do something
concrete about the conditions that
surround them organizers do best working
in the places that they know working
with the people that they know being
intelligent about how you organize your
time so that you don't wind up with
congestive heart failure as i did five
years ago so that you're actually on the
planet long enough to do the good that
drove you to do this work in the first
place it's probably something that is
doable I think what we lack is a certain
amount of faith how many of you in the
audience would describe yourself as ever
so slightly cynical about the president
and the future and I see a show hands
and well that may be our biggest enemy
the most eloquent disclaimers and the
most eloquent critiques of the talks i
give are from folk who know so much that
they can counter every positive point I
make with five or six negative ones I
agree my argument my approach my dommage
as the french would say has lots of
holes in it but if you look at the life
dr. king what do you see see a guy who
did it anyway
and after I'm suggested we have to do we
have to do it anyway thank you
you
the preceding program was brought to you
by Teachers College Columbia University
please visit us online at iTunes TC
columbia edu